one more question here today from Anya
from patreon she says I don't know if
you can answer this question perhaps
it's more for your wives or maybe it's
more for Shelby here I have managed to
reduce my clothing purchasing I'll
purchase something I really love after a
few months of thinking about it but I
have a hard time with makeup and perfume
I love all the organic stuff and there's
more and more of that now we also had a
question from Anne Marie about the same
similar question but about candles and
one more question from Karen about books
and so I think first off let me just say
this I think the problem isn't the
things the problem here is the love you
mentioned Marie Kondo I think it's
really helpful in fact I got into an
argument on Twitter this morning with
James Ulta Chur because he's like Marie
condos bs I'm like no she helps a lot of
people with their stuff Twitter the best
place to have arguments well I was
trying to stand up for Marie Kondo
because I think that what she does a lot
of it has to do with the stuff right she
helps people deal with the stuff the
external clutter is a physical
manifestation of what's going on inside
us and once you start dealing with that
stuff outwardly you can look inward and
say oh I've got some financial clutter
I've got some mental clutter I've got
some spiritual clutter I've got some
internal clutter the emotional clutter
the psychological clutter all these
clutters that are going on inside of me
I deal with this stuff first the problem
however with the stuff is when we
cherish it too much it's the one problem
I have with the the connemara method is
which talks about the cherishing keeping
the things that you cherish I don't want
you to cherish your things they're just
things right I don't want you to love
your things they're just things I want
you to love the people around you I want
you to cherish your relationships with
experiences or maybe even the memories
without being too attached to the
physical goods themselves because what
happens if you lose them what happens if
they burn up in a fire then you've lost
your love all of a sudden no I don't
think so so I think what we need to let
go of first is the love of the things
and then figure out how do these things
add value and then what is the
appropriate amount for you and not
didn't don't go past the appropriate
amount so
Shelbie makeup perfume candles books
clothing these are all things that
people struggle with right and all
things that I've struggled with
throughout my life as well right but I
think it comes back to we've talked a
lot about boundaries during this and
it's yeah how much do you need to
actually be happy with what you have
because if we're talking things like
makeup if you just buy all this makeup
like if there's a huge makeup culture on
YouTube it's really a problem and if you
paid enough attention to that you'll
think you need every eyeshadow release
that comes out but you have to set
boundaries because realistically you
will never work through all that stuff
if you buy it so aside from like is it
clearing up your space it's like can I
actually use that is this money just
funneling into a product that I'll never
really touch you get value for am I
gonna use it once or twice even though
and then move on from like you didn't
the clothes when you're a teenager
exactly yeah word this once or twice and
now I've moved on I think there is a
fast makeup culture right now on YouTube
for sure well my mother's it looked like
someone was trying to start a makeup
store when when I was going through her
things like she had boxes and bins and
tubs of makeup I think some of us from
the 80s like wow what was going on there
but she it was like yeah all she needed
was the pink Cadillac and she could have
just gone around selling makeup
everything everything would have been
fine
Ryan yes what it what candles candles no
I mean I agree she'll be about
boundaries I mean that's what that's
what I feel like Anja needs to do here
like she needs to set up boundaries for
herself so go buy your candles go buy
perfume buy makeup I mean if that's
truly gonna add value to your life but
you've got to know when to stop like
whether it's a 30-30 rule the one in one
out rule or the one in ten out rule
whatever it is like Anja if you don't
set boundaries up for yourself yes
you're gonna drive yourself crazy and
you're gonna be in a tornado of makeup
and perfume I'll put a link to the video
for that in the show notes as well start
with a clean slate getting rid of the
excess that you don't need it helps you
understand what you actually do need
we're overwhelmed with stuff we often
think we need all of it oh my god I'm
gonna hold on to this just in case
of course the just in case item
we never get around to using them just
in case right there just sitting there
our house becomes a giant storage locker
you